la moitié des 130 centres de tri postaux
en france sont également grève contre la
réforme de la sécurité sociale et
solidaire avec les cheminots reportage à
rouen d'abord et dans d'autres centres
pascal golomer l'ugb aziz
ici on n'est pas en grève pour des
intérêts étroits et égoïste de
catégorielles on est en grève contre le
plan juppé
le centre de tri de sotteville-lès-rouen
bloqués depuis lundi soir depuis le vote
que la grève va m'enlever trois
assemblées générales chaque jour est
toujours le même mot d'ordre qui revient
dans les conversations non à la casse
des acquis sociaux non à la remise en
cause des régimes de retraite beaucoup
polleit disait est ce qu'on va subir
toutes les attaques
à chaque fois en répondant suspendu 24
heures souhaité aller plus loin le fait
que les cheminots et montrait la voie
c'est le cas de le dire a décidé
d'actions ce soir 50 des 130 centres de
tri de la poste sont occupés avec 50 à
90% de grévistes
une grève qui ne s'étant pour l'instant
qu'à une vingtaine de bureaux à paris
grenoble lyon ou valence soyez-en les
guichets reste ouvert les facteurs font
encore leur tournée murray distribution
du courrier pourrait devenir de plus en
plus chaotique dans les jours qui
viennent si le mouvement se poursuit et
c'est bien l'intention des principaux
syndicats qui appellent partout à la
grève reconductible